we just started flying airplanes a
little over 100 years ago and here we
are
with the dawn of the billionaire space
race we are seeing the first days of an
economy that actually exists in space
[Music]
that begs the question of what happens
when money needs to be transacted in
space from an individual living in space
or working in space to another
individual living and working in space
right now that transaction would have to
go down to the earth and back which is
fine if you're in a low earth orbit like
the international space station a little
less fine if you're on the moon and not
fine at all if you're on mars where it
can take 20 minutes 30 minutes or more
for a transaction to go back and then
that time again to go forth this isn't
like a theoretical problem i had a
chance to speak with astronaut scott
kelly um and he talked about buying a
dozen roses for his wife one day and the
incredible difficulties he had just
getting an internet signal in space that
he was able to do very very basic
banking if he was incredibly patient but
that anything more sophisticated than a
simple transfer was really untenable so
i think that really starts to open up
this world where what happens when the
first structure is built on the moon
what happens in the world that elon musk
has envisioned where there's 10 000
people living on mars by the middle of
this century what happens in the world
where others have envisioned millions of
people living on mars by the end of this
century we're not going to want those
transactions to have to travel the great
distance to earth and back we also have
an interesting opportunity here because
there are no economies on these other
planetary bodies including the moon and
and mars and it doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense to spend a currency
that is minted by a central bank that
only has power within existing borders
it would be like trying to print a
dollar in japan or like trying to print
a peso in china it just doesn't make
sense so why would we be spending
dollars on mars what i think is most
interesting about the idea of this
interplanetary space economy is that the
countries that are minting the currency
that we're spending today are by
definition not on those planets
and there are regulations in place
already today that say if you put a flag
on a planet um that doesn't mean that
you own the planet or even the land
around that flag it's a fun gesture and
the same international agreements will
exist on mars why not imagine the way
economies work on these interplanetary
bodies
there's so many problems with the
central bank system we've seen it in the
headlines time and time again simply
just inflation but exchange rates
foreign exchange transaction problems
delays countries that don't trust each
other central banks that are committing
fraud against their citizens why not
reimagine that we don't destroy
ourselves absolutely someday we will
have the need for currency in space uh
whether it's uh orbiting hotel or
something on the moon or something on
mars you know it just makes sense that
it's crypto right because it's not you
know a fiat currency from any particular
government these so-called blockchains
or distributed ledgers really only work
on relatively short distances because of
the time it takes light to move from one
side of the earth to the other
our financial transactions can move at
about that same speed and that's fine if
you're on earth but the speed of light
going from here to mars is a huge delay
so the question then becomes how do you
sync up a distributed network of
computers that are helping process
transactions without a central middleman
across such vast distances
the answer that question isn't simple
but there are people that are trying to
solve that